What do a lipstick, a microwave, and car paint
have in common?
I bet the question caught you by surprise.
Well, should you want to analyze the manufacturing
process of each of these products, you'll
find that in all three cases mica is used.
Mica, from the Latin word "mico"-"I shine"-is
a very special group of minerals: in fact,
their easy and perfect flaking, even by simple
rubbing with fingers, splits them into very
thin but elastic and flexible foils and scales,
with a characteristic mother-of-pearl luster.
Their versatility of use is remarkable: in
addition to the possibility of being combined
with other layers of material, they can be
ground and used in the form of powders or
flakes and possess a natural low electrical
and thermal conductivity.
Because of these properties, it's possible
to find their use in most cosmetics on the
market, such as eye shadows and foundations,
but also in making paints, oven windows, heating
systems, and even toothpastes.
Of course, just as with other minerals, mica
must be sorted, mined and processed before
it's placed on the market for sale.
If you have never heard of them, perhaps I
can also explain why.
According to the Observatory of Economic Complexity
at the Institute of Technology in Cambridge,
Massachusetts, in 2021 the market for micas
had a total commercial value of two hundred
and thirty seven million dollars.
In purely economic terms, these minerals participate
in only 0,000011% of the global market.
A trifle in practice, when put in relation
to their variety of uses.
The country that exported the largest amount,
in monetary terms, was China, with a total
of sixty-one million dollars.
This was followed by The Netherlands, India,
Madagascar and France.
In terms of imports, however, the main buyers
turn out to be Japan, China, Germany, the
United States and Belgium.
Until a few years ago, the use of mica in
cosmetic products was a source of pride for
the major multinationals in the sector, because
these are elements that are already present
in nature and t herefore not synthesized in
laboratories, which allows them to add the
"natural" stamp to their makeup of choice.
This was, as I said, until a few years ago.
Today, I want to focus on two of the nations
I just mentioned-India and Madagascar.
Similar to what happens in other so-called
underdeveloped or developing countries, the
logic of profit involves costs beyond those
in money.
I am talking, in this case, about the exploitation
of labor, which, unfortunately, also and especially
concerns children.
And to talk about it, I have referred to two
investigations centered on surveys, interviews
and field observations supported by statistics
regarding the volume of domestic mica trades.
But we'll get to that slowly.
Let's start with India.
In 2016, a Thomson Reuters Foundation survey
conducted over three months in the Indian
states of Bihar, Jharkhand, Rajasthan and
Andhra Pradesh shed light on a widespread
reality of child labor in so-called ghost
mines.
The main type mined in India is muscovite,
also known as white or common mica, which,
although it can be used as an insulating material,
is also used to give shine to make-up and
skincare products.
According to information extracted from the
Zauba platform, which catalogs data regarding
Indian import/export, Bihar exported more
than one hundred thousand tons of mica in
2015.
For the Indian Bureau of Mines, on the other
hand, the whole of India would have produced
about 20 thousand in the same year.
According to Reuters, this huge discrepancy
is explained by the fact that 70 percent of
production depended on the illegal mining
of mica, conducted mostly in abandoned forests
and quarries.
And here we come to the darker side of ghost
mining: the tender age of the victims involved.
In fact, according to reports by the children's
rights advocacy association Bachpan Bachao
Andolan, in June 2016 alone, 20 children died
in the mica mines, double the monthly average.
In fact, widespread health risks related to
the lack of proper safety systems and continuous
exposure to dust include respiratory problems,
skin infections, and deep cuts.
This happens because, in most cases, children
are forced to collect the mica with their
bare hands, and although these minerals aren't
harmful, the environment from which they are
extracted can be.
Unlike adults, moreover, children can enter
deeper cavities and so, more easily prone
to collapse, where they get to spend up to
eight hours.
And they do it for a miserable pay.
We are talking about between 50 and 300 rupees,
or between 80 cents and 4 dollars a day.
Since in 90 percent of cases, these deaths
go unreported to local authorities, the actual
deaths could be far higher than those reported.
"I didn't know how dangerous the work in the
mines is.
Had i known, I would never have let him go,"
farmer Vasdev Rai Pratap, father of a 16-year-old
boy who died in June 2016 in Jharkhand, told
Reuters.
"They said it took almost a day to dig out
his body after the mine collapsed.
They cremated him without telling me."Pratap
then reveals that he accepted a payment of
one hundred thousand Indian rupees, equal
to $1,500.
He did this in exchange for his silence to
avoid ending illegal mining on protected forest
lands that bring income to some of India's
poorest areas.
By protected forest land Reuters refers to
the Forest Conservation Act, passed by India's
parliament in 1980, a directive that resulted
in a drastic reduction in mining and, in the
specific case of mica, led to a reduction
in the 730 licensed quarries operating in
1964, to a maximum of 148 still active in
1986.
And in 2014, the Indian Bureau of Mines reported
only two mica mining licenses in the entire
state of Bihar, which is far from the reality
of the situation.
As early as 1993, Sanjay Kumar had documented
in his book Problems and Prospects of Mineral
Industry in India the existence of widespread
illegal mines especially in the Bihar Mica
belt that, although abandoned and lacking
machinery, were still being exploited to sell
the mineral to those who demanded it.
It's possible to assume that unlicensed quarries,
hidden in dense forests, proliferated to meet
the constant domestic and international demand
for mica.To understand the phenomenon of ghost
mining, we need to dig deeper.
Reuters' investigation is intertwined with
an interesting March 2016 report titled "Beauty
and a Beast."
It was published by the network of international
organizations Terre des Hommes, which fights
against child exploitation and discrimination,
in collaboration with SOMO, an independent
Dutch research center investigating multinational
corporations.
According to the data collected, in the year
2015/2016, underage workers amounted to about
20,000, scattered in more than 300 villages
in the state of Jharkhand alone.
Page 21 of the document lays out the percentages
of the population residing in the states of
Jharkhand and Bihar living below the poverty
line, their literacy level, and the level
of education of children and teenagers between
the ages of 6 and 14.
It immediately jumps out that these are much
worse data than the Indian average.
Which might suggest a link to child labor.
It's likely, in fact, that children find themselves
working to make up, albeit with little pocket
money, for the economic condition of their
families, to the detriment of their education.
Terre des Hommes also refers to another problem
endemic to the Indian reality: castes.
According to a 2011 census referring to the
sub-districts of the two federated states
of Bihar and Jharkhand, in the largest of
them, namely Rajauli, Gawan and Domchanch,
the percentages of "dalits," the so-called
untouchables, or individuals of the lowest
social status belonging to groups placed outside
the pattern of the 4 traditional castes, are
29, 16 and 14 percent of the total population,
respectively.
If this reality is still so widespread, despite
the formal abolition of untouchability and
the discrimination that comes with it, what
are the Indian government and the multinational
corporations that import products from India
doing to counter it?
In January 2017, some 20 companies in the
cosmetics and electronics industries set up
the Responsible Mica Initiative, aimed at
funding educational and social projects to
remove not only children, but also families,
from working in the mines.
To date, more than 80 multinational companies
join, including Chanel, l'Oréal, Merck and
Shiseido.
Criticism, however, hasn't been slow in coming.
First, it's worth noting that Beauty and a
Beast clearly mentions, in chapters 7 and
8, the major companies involved in the mica
market.
Although Terre des Hommes and SOMO don't link
them directly to child labor, they accuse
them of supporting its perpetuation by continuing
to buy minerals from India.It's not hard to
imagine that these same companies, in anticipation
of enormous image damage, have run for cover.
For example, pigment company Kuncai, the largest
importer of mica from Jharkhand and Bihar
in the first half of 2015, with 6200 tons
worth 201 million Indian rupees, immediately
stated it would help Terre des Hommes “save"
10,000 children.
The Jharkhand government also followed su
it, promising to legalize the mines to also
regularize work activities within them.
Unfortunately, however, it seems that nowadays
the situation hasn't changed at all.
The pandemic hasn't only worsened the conditions
of those living in contact with mines but
has created a vacuum in terms of information
on the issue.
In 2021, the Thomson Reuters Foundation again
called out multinational cosmetics companies.
The reason was that the funds allocated to
the Responsible Mica Initiative, about a million
dollars a year, wouldn’t be used to combat
child labor, since children would seem to
continue to report infections and be victims
of accidents of various kinds.
Then there is another problem on the horizon.
There has been criticism of the world of make-up.
Yet, the electronics industry has no less
impact on the global micas market.
To realize this, let’s now switch hemispheres,
and move to a country that is in worse shape
than the Indian Federated States: Madagascar.
We are talking, according to World Bank data,
about a purely agricultural nation that has
a poverty rate of 80 percent.
This percentage of the population, in fact,
lives on little more than two dollars a day.
According to the World Food Program, food
insecurity in Madagascar, also worsened by
frequent environmental disasters, involves
about 9 million people out of 28 total.
If we admit the existence of a correlation
between poverty and child labor, what I am
about to say will not surprise you.
In 2018, according to UNICEF, 47 percent of
Malagasy children between the ages of 5 and
17 were employed as labor force.
This reality is even more daunting in the
south of the country, which has been plagued
for nearly four decades by the anti-state
violence of so-called dahalo bandits, the
"cattle raiders."
According to Amnesty International, some 4,000
people, including thieves, civilians, security
forces, and soldiers, died between 2015 and
2019 as a result of the government's hard
response to the dahalo.
The raids and repression continue to this
day to claim victims.
It's precisely in this context that most of
the mica mining activities, in which children
are involved, are concentrated.
In this regard, in 2019, three years after
Beauty and a Beast, Terre des Hommes and SOMO
released a new report.
It found the presence on Malagasy territory
of 201 deposits of phlogopite, a mica that
is used in the manufacture of electrical and
thermal insulators, 176 of which would be
located in the southern regions of Ihorombe,
Androy and Anosy.
The data strongly clashes with that reported
by the Bureau du Cadastre Minier de Madagascar,
which, as of July 2019, recorded 50 valid
concessions for mica mining, or a quarter
of the mines actually exploited.
How is this possible?
On page 23, the paper lays out what the supply
chain for mica is in Madagascar.
About 20 thousand miners are involved in extracting
the required minerals, which are then acquired
by 400 buyers, including independents and
employees of multinational companies operating
in the territory.
Then it's the turn of the transporters, who
take the micas to five companies that are
responsible for sorting and dividing them.
One of these is Tri-H, whose complex is located
in Tolagnaro, the capital of the Anosy region.
It takes six hours of driving on narrow, unpaved
roads to reach the plant by truck.
Finally, goods are piled up at Port d'Ehola,
built in 2009 by the Malagasy government and
used as a docking port for cruise ships, cargo
ships, and reefers.
Compared to mica mined in India, in Madagascar's
case this mineral goes to meet the needs of
different sectors and apparently has only
one interlocutor.
In 2017, about 90 percent of the mica mined
in Madagascar was exported by sea to China,
where it was used as a component to produce
wires, cables and household appliances, as
well as finding use in the automotive industry.
As Terre des Hommes shows on page 52 of its
report, the four main multinational corporations
importing Madagascar's mica are Chinese, and
engaged in the construction, hi-tech and electronics
sectors, and would buy the mineral for a very
small sum: around 4 cents per kilo.
Now we come to the sorest note, the trait
that unites India and Madagascar in this circuit
centered on labor exploitation.
Of the 20,000 Malagasy miners, at least 10,000
are between the ages of 5 and 17.
Terre des Hommes has reported cases of very
young miners who are only fed at night because
they are constantly busy during the day, suffering
frequent back and headaches from too many
hours spent in uncomfortable positions and
oxygen deprivation inside the tunnels.
In 2019, NBC conducted an investigation on
Malagasy soil, following in the footsteps
of Terre des Hommes, and quietly, without
announcing its arrival.
Arriving in Amboasary South, 70km west of
Tolagnaro, reporters took photos of women
and children intent on sorting nearby mined
micas.
The mothers interviewed confessed to earning
the equivalent of 3 dollars a week, working
for 13 hours a day.
At the time, NBC asked for an interview with
Tri-H, whose manager, Haja Ranahary, said
he was aware of child labor in the mica mines,
adding, however, that "it's not our problem.
It's not our fault, but the parents of the
children [...]. If it wasn't for the mica,
all these people would be bandits and, right
now, they would be stealing cars."
Data exposed by Terre des Hommes, however,
say that in the southern regions of Madagascar
only 12 percent of children finish secondary
school, and just 25 percent of the population
has access to clean water.
Maybe, just maybe, it's the state that is
lacking, and it's the companies that are profiting
from it.
The multinationals surveyed, including Japan's
Panasonic, America's Electrolock and China's
CRRC said they were unaware of the reality
of child labor and would investigate their
own supply chains.
The fact remains that widespread monitoring
is very difficult, in part because the confluence
of some of the mica extracted by Malagasy
children within the flow of mica from India
makes it virtually impossible to identify
the products into which it goes.
And when we consider that many other companies
including Ford, Fiat, Isovolta, and Boeing
rely on mica sheets to make their cars and
airplanes, the plot thickens.
Obviously, I don't have a solution to the
problem, nor am I here to tell you to stop
buying an eyeshadow or a car.
Unfortunately, although critical for its insulating
properties and resistance to high voltage,
mica is still a niche market, on which not
much of a spotlight is shining.
In short, it's hard to see what goes where.
As I anticipated, several companies, such
as L'Oréal, haven’t given up on mica in
favor of synthetics, continuing to purchase
it only "through a transparent and traceable
supply chain," in order to promote economic
development and improve the living conditions
of Indian workers.
Britain's Lush, on the other hand, had already
shown its intention in 2014 to remove all
traces of so-called natural mica from its
products because of its connection to child
labor and, as of 2018, has switched to making
synthetic mica.
Well, I am done here for today.
The intention was to draw attention to a problem
that exists and is very little talked about.
So I sincerely hope, despite the amount of
data, that I have managed to offer you a fairly
clear and comprehensive analysis.
Thanks for your attention and we’ll see
you in the next video.
Ciao!